jack what's up man
yo
what's up boys what's up not much how
are you
um [ __ ] fantastic can i curse on here
you can do whatever you want man when
you're changing the world you can do
whatever you want you got shoes yeah
it's my world i got crocs is that a
stupid question yeah let's go
i mean absolutely legendary interview
yesterday they want to make fun of the
closet they want to make fun of the
clothes they need to say well i got pink
crocs on so uh have fun dude
justin bieber crocs man get with the
culture old man
man thanks for having me
all right let's get into uh into all
this stuff you've got a couple different
things going on first you announced an
api yesterday let's first talk about the
api what exactly uh it is and how it
works
yeah api application application program
interface so
uh we think we're building the most
inclusive novel monetary infrastructure
on the planet and we first advertise
that and allow consumers to interface
with it in a mobile app and that's
strike the application um but we detach
the actual infrastructure from the app
itself and allow anyone in the world to
use that infrastructure to gain benefit
from what we deem the best monetary
network in the planet which is bitcoin
and so you saw twitter integrate it
but from a high level what this monetary
network allows you to do it's instant
global and relatively free physical
value settlement so that benefits
merchants so that they don't have to use
processing companies like visa to
achieve finality that benefits internet
companies so that they can achieve a
financial experience globally for all of
their users that's remitting money
that's micro payments that's creator
economies and so we want to enable the
infrastructure that we have and really
liberate the world financially and make
the world a more connected place and so
now any business any online site any
merchant any creators marketplace any
social media can gain the benefit of the
world's first singular global monetary
standard that is bitcoin uh and so it's
it's really my my best effort uh in
advancing the world monetarily uh and
it'd be stupid to think that everyone in
the world would download my mobile
application and instead give them the
infrastructure to integrate into what
the world already uses today so
i know a lot more than most just given
that you and i've been talking about
this for a while and you've been very
kind of uh
clear about what you wanted to build i'm
an investor in the company so highly
biased but uh i think i
and you both agree uh the open system is
going to beat the closed system and so
what i want to uh kind of walk through
is a couple of the nuances here to make
sure people really understand the first
is if you have uh let's say venmo and i
have a different payment application in
the legacy world i can't actually send
you money or you can't venmo me if let's
say i'm on cash app or something like
that and so these closed networks end up
being siloed from each other but with
the lightning network integrations
explain how a strike user can actually
communicate uh value or send value to
somebody who's using a completely
different app and doesn't even know what
strike is
yeah it's not an intuitive concept but
here let's walk through this it may take
me a second but let's walk through this
from a super high level um a twitter
user in the us can send a tweet and that
tweet can be received by a user in japan
by a user in africa
by user in the middle east
right
now
what if though that user in japan wanted
to tip you pomp for this amazing show
and your amazing tweets and you had your
venmo account linked
out of luck
out of luck
and so
what the internet did for communication
is before if you wanted to send a
message to someone in japan a long time
ago you would write it on a thinly
sliced piece of wood and you'd send a
[ __ ] pigeon to go fly it across and
hope that they delivered you know the
pigeon spits your note out it's whoever
you want to read it you're like hey what
are you doing for dinner and a pigeon
spit is all over the message that you
tried to send now you can send a tweet
what the internet did to communication
is it gave the world a singular global
protocol so
whether you want to ask a friend what
they're doing for dinner whether you
want to google the best restaurant in
town whether you want to buy tickets to
the bear game all of those communication
efforts are all just an internet request
https tcpip request the internet is one
singular protocol for communication so
now you can use that protocol to send a
message again to a user in japan to a
user in saudi arabia to user in south
africa it all works globally now let's
revisit money today today money is still
in pigeon land
money is still in
uh writing of course carriage to deliver
newspaper land
where if you're in the u.s you've got
cash app and venmo
you know western union is for remittance
but if you go to starbucks do you use
western union no you use your visa card
but if you're online and you buy some
merchandise you use stripe they're
independent bifurcated closed networks
to accomplish monetary settlement what
bitcoin and the lightning network does
is it gives the world a global singular
protocol for monetary settlement in the
same way that the internet is a global
singular protocol for communications
okay and so now all of a sudden pom if
your venmo account is linked to your
twitter account can someone from japan
tip you a penny no
but if you're hooked into the singular
global interoperable monetary protocol
for the world can they tip you a penny
over the lightning and bitcoin network
yes and there are so many precursors
that people don't appreciate in order to
have that you'd have to have a money
that works everywhere in the world that
lives outside of a governance by a
nation state that lives outside of an
issue in termination state from a
company so bitcoin as the only digital
bear instrument on the planet is a
precursor to this experience and then on
top of that you need a protocol that can
allow it to achieve instant
physical bear instrument settlement
and free
physical bear instrument settlement and
that's the lightning network and
combined
what the internet did for communication
bitcoin and the lightning network is
doing for money and you violently see
that with twitter my phone won't stop
[ __ ] going off hey thanks from japan
hey thanks from saudi arabia
no other monetary network paypal
venmo cash ab chime can do that except
this one and so rant over but that's
what this is about i've had people in
the last couple of hours somebody sent
me 25 bucks somebody sent me a penny
somebody sent me a dollar somebody just
now while we were on said sending tips
while the show with jack mullers is
going on just to illustrate the point
right literally people are just sending
this over twitter now what i want to do
is i want to make sure that we hammer
home the point of separating bitcoin the
asset from bitcoin the network nobody
claimed that this was good marketing but
the difference between bitcoin the asset
and bitcoin the network is really
important here because actually what
they're sending me and what they're
sending you is not bitcoin they are
sending dollars across the lightning
network using those rails so describe
how that's occurring and why it's so
important that the rails can be used
regardless of the actual or agnostic to
the currency that the sender and
receiver wants to use
yeah so
i've been working on the lightning
network in bitcoin for close to a decade
and initially the lightning network for
those that don't know we set out to
achieve two things as a distributed set
of open source developers working on it
it was one can we
accomplish and solve the variable time
it takes for bitcoin to achieve finality
so traditionally the wall street journal
write a headline your bitcoin
transactions may take days right you
can't buy coffee with a transaction that
takes [ __ ] days the second is your
bitcoin transactions are really
expensive they're too expensive right
the throughput can't match visa and it's
too expensive to buy coffee so the
lightning network was can we solve those
two can we make finality instantly can
we make finality free and then when once
we accomplish that pomp we realize like
hold on a second oh my god this is a
monetary network that is able to achieve
settlement at no cost anywhere in the
world and instantly and if you [ __ ]
bitcoin the asset for a second [ __ ] the
digital gold thing for a second tell
mike your sailor to just like shut his
piper for one [ __ ] second and let's
talk about the fact that the visa
network can't do that the paypal network
can't do that the western union network
can't do that matter of fact no monetary
network in human history can do that so
instead of making people spend their
bitcoin which they don't want to do if
you just hold your bitcoin you just get
rich why would you spend it make people
call up an accountant with all the tax
consequences make people go to harvard
and get a cryptography course to set up
a lightning network node uh-uh what if i
allowed you to link your checking
account or your debit card just like you
do for cash app or venmo
and allowed you to use this monetary
network under the hood to gain the
instant free global benefits that it
gives you so let's walk through a
remittance example if i'm sending money
from the u.s to japan
i have my chase checking account linked
strike is going to debit the money from
my chase checking account i send 100 to
japan strike behind the scenes is gonna
take a hundred dollars out of my chase
account i don't need to know what
bitcoin is how it works i don't need to
think it's going up or down i just have
my checking account link strike takes a
hundred dollars programmatically
converts into bitcoin on the lightning
network zips that value across oceans
across borders all the way to japan and
that physical value that physical bare
digital instrument bitcoin is going to
get from the united states in this
gorgeous [ __ ] women's closet into
japan in one second and at no cost
and then we just convert it into
japanese yen because it's the only
digital bear instrument global commodity
that has the liquidity profile on every
single currency 24 7.
so we go from dollars
bitcoin bang
japanese yen give them the japanese yen
and all of a sudden nobody knows bitcoin
was involved in that and bitcoin the
asset and whether it's the better
version of gold or not doesn't matter
we're just using it the network to make
for more efficient global singular
monetary standards settlement
and that's the most innovative thing of
all time i mean are you kidding me
not only is it the most innovative thing
of all time i think what uh people don't
really understand here is uh what you've
built with strike is global
infrastructure but you didn't have to go
raise a bunch of money and go build that
infrastructure yourself what we have is
we have a group of volunteers on the
internet now tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of people that are
setting this infrastructure up and
participating in the network in a way
that previously was nearly impossible
right visa had to go spend a bunch of
money to go build out the visa network
make sure that they had service in
certain countries make sure that there's
uptime and that they could service all
of those different customers and
merchants the lightning network exists
and all you have to do whether you're a
merchant whether you're a user whether
your strike etc is just simply plug into
the system and now you have access to a
global network and it doesn't matter
whether it's el salvador or strike or me
as an individual or a small business
we're all just one single interface or
one single node on that network
yeah let me put you this way mom have
you ever received a venmo payment from a
service that wasn't another venmo user
never
never right
okay how the [ __ ] did i get a payment
from japan onto my strike law
um strikes not in japan
yep
we're just on a network that's open open
networks beat closed networks here's
another fascinating thing naive
president of el salvador i'm not a
politician
i'm not speaking on his political
efforts i'm speaking about his bitcoin
efforts he looks like a genius you want
to know why because twitter just made
his country better
there are developers in london right now
working on the bitcoin protocol that are
making his country better do you think
el salvador
pomp population of 7 million it's
smaller than [ __ ] manhattan do you
think they have the resources to
continue to be on the bleeding edge of
financial infrastructure no you know
who's doing it for them jack dorsey jack
mallors bitcoin core developers mit
professors that's open network network
effects economies of scale benefit so
now
people
in el salvador can save 400 million
dollars by remitting money over twitter
instead of western union you know how
much work he did for that
[ __ ] zero
[ __ ] zero he didn't do [ __ ] he just
plugged into an open network and kicked
his feet back and trolled the entire
internet now let's look at twitter do
you want to know
twitter cares about engagement right
twitter's not taking a cut of any of
this they want users to use the platform
today
people are going onto twitter to remit
money instead of tweet talk about
engagement they just integrated an open
monetary network and they disrupted an
entire industry on accident so people
are going to tweet people are going to
dm their friends and now people are
going to remit money to their family and
now people because el salvador is on a
bitcoin standard now people can go check
out at starbucks with their twitter
account
so twitter became a better issuing
payment method at starbucks in el
salvador a better remittance option for
those in western union and now i can go
online and on twitter and post a sexy
picture in my six pack
and anyone in the world can tip me and i
just get spendable dollars twitter
became a better content creation
acquiring platform in one integration
it's the most insane thing ever that is
network effects you can't compete with
[ __ ] like that you know paypal all the
you know you either integrate or you die
i mean
same with the internet those that didn't
get on the internet dead those that
won't get on bitcoin and lightning are
going to die is it inevitable at this
point that every single one of them have
to integrate like is the economic upside
and the uh incentive so strong now that
all i have to do is simply plug into the
system and then i just empower my users
to do all of this so it's almost more of
an opportunity cost not to do it than it
is to do it
yeah
and and so i i mean i got them all right
where i want i got
ooh
i got them right where i want them
because here's their problem
the the valuation of paypal you know the
market capital paypal is a proxy to the
to the network they've built right all
the merchants on the network all the
users on the network if i create a new
version of twitter pomp would you
download and get on board no because
there's no one on the network
these companies have built up networks
and so if paypal becomes interoperable
with an open standard the network goes
to zero when i go to a paypal merchant i
don't have to use paypal to check out i
could use whatever the [ __ ] i want and
so they're at a crosshairs they know
they have to innovate they they they're
not stupid i mean these people are money
makers they're not dumb
but what do you do
you just destroy the 300 billion dollars
it took you a couple decades to build
it's tough i don't know and here's the
other thing in an open network the best
experience the best brand wins if that
wasn't true and it was whoever got there
first then i'd be using myspace
right
okay so these guys have to invite free
market open competition
all of a sudden all of a sudden if i go
check out at a starbucks and it's out
nowadays if i go to a starbucks how are
you paying for that coffee that what a
stupid [ __ ] question either my visa
card or like apple pay what a dumb
question what are you paying with idiot
if there's an open network standard how
are you paying for that coffee i'm using
my twitter account to pay for it i'm
using my facebook account to pay for it
i'm using this pink wallet that my
nephew built to pay for i'm using a
encrypted cypherpunk node in my basement
to pay for it and these people have
these closed walled gardens that they've
used for years and and they're i think
they're scared of competition as well so
i don't know and i don't care um
in open networks new participants are
additive so when they do come onto the
network it makes everyone that's already
on it's stronger so i mean either you
could join and make me better or you can
resist it and die but either way i win
so i don't give a [ __ ] we talk a lot
about paypal and venmo uh as kind of
these peer-to-peer things and i think
people still uh inaccurately believe
bitcoin only to be uh this peer-to-peer
type service where it's cute that i can
send you a dollar across the bitcoin
network uh with the creation of this api
it feels like major merchants small
businesses online stores etc now get to
actually integrate technology that is
superior uh for all the reasons we just
discussed but it puts not the paypal and
venmo alone in the crosshairs of this
technology instead bigger things like
visa mastercard stripe etc talk about
kind of the more traditional payment
processors and kind of how you see this
technology competing with them not just
with uh the consumer facing you know uh
kind of peer-to-peer apps like venmo or
paypal
yeah let's talk about costco i don't
know random s p 500 one of the biggest
retailers in the world
right costco gets charged call it a
solid 290 300 basis points to accept a
payment from a payment processor like
visa right 2.9 for the kids at home
that's a lot of money um all of a sudden
and why what are they paying for
they're paying for finality they're
paying for the dollars that someone is
pledging to pay them to guarantee to
settle because god knows the dollars
that are sitting in my pocket if i go
check out at costco don't magically
appear in the cash register how does all
that fanciness work visa takes on the
credit risk visa takes on the
counterparty risk visa takes on the
balance sheet float visa takes on a ton
of fixed cost and necessary
intermediaries to achieve that
settlement and they charge someone like
costco 2.9 for that this new monetary
network the lightning network compared
to the visa network guess how much the
lightning network charges for finality
zero
zero
and so let's imagine a world where i go
check out at costco and i tap my phone
scan a qr code swipe a card whatever
your preference is i don't care the
dollars are going to leave me convert to
bitcoin zip over this new network the
lightning network and then convert back
to dollars for costco and costco i could
charge costco five basis points
0.05
for that and guess how much of that is
profit in my pocket one hundred percent
you know visa tried to charge five basis
points they'd go bankrupt because the
fixed costs disallow it
and so we're not only talking about
fancy tipping methods on twitter i'm
talking about disrupting everything pop
in the same way that a google search or
me streaming this on youtube or me
tweeting something it's all an http
request on the internet a remittance
payment a payment for my costco
paying my allowance to my kid is all
going to be a bolt 11 lightning network
invoice and money is going to
consolidate on a singular standard and
those that live in these independent
monetary networks are going to die in
the same way that newspapers did when
the internet came out i've got my
brother john here with me he's probably
your biggest fan he literally put his
hat on before you came on this i'm gonna
wear my hat like mahlers does uh what
questions you got for jack what's up
jack congrats on the twitter integration
you are truly changing the world your
energy and enthusiasm is absolutely
contagious i love it i love it so i was
going to ask you about all the api stuff
that you guys just rolled out but i just
want to know what is your end goal is it
to replace the payment solutions in the
monetary systems today like what is your
end goal here
no i mean
as an entrepreneur i want to build one
of the biggest companies in the world
and i think i'm uniquely positioned to
do that and it has nothing to do with me
and it just is where bitcoin is in its
life cycle what's what it's doing and
the the time i'm alive right now on the
planet um but my end goal is really
simple the mission of the company is to
econo empower economic freedom for
everybody and build a more connected
financial world and the same way that
the internet connected all of us in a
communication sense i think bitcoin and
the lighting network can connect all of
us financially and people don't
appreciate i mean the dematerialization
that the internet did for the
communications industry that's a really
fancy word salad [ __ ] right but look at
how it changed the world today
envisioning a world without the internet
seems surreal it seems disgusting uh and
we're seeing that same dematerialization
for money right now and so just pause
and think about envision none of us know
what's going to happen and so not only
are we making the world more efficient
and it's fun to mock western union and
stuff but you really have to believe
that we're pushing humanity in the right
direction and we're empowering people
we're building on financial inclusion
we're building and improving on the
quality of lives of people all over the
planet in creating an environment that
fosters more innovation and humans are
tool builders i mean i'd like to leave
the place the world a better place than
when i joined it and so
all of those things and uh i don't know
a more ambitious brand or mission to
spend my time on so
i love that i love that yeah i think
just users will flow to anything that's
convenient cheap and secure so um what
for this api actually what like what
other systems can kind of integrate with
it so you guys have already launched
with twitter what other systems do you
see integrating with it without giving
much uh too much like entire information
that you have going on at strike
yeah so okay let's revisit twitter for
example so you're talking about social
media companies they want engagement uh
they want global engagement by the way
so now all of a sudden people are going
on twitter today to remit money people
are going on twitter today to post their
blog and get tips from anyone in the
world it became a much more
inclusive place for monetary action do
you think facebook is just gonna sit and
watch that right and here's the other
thing do you think facebook is gonna
launch their own cryptocurrency to
compete with that no because they'd be
operating on a separate network they
don't get the network benefits this is a
shot call of you either join the
singular network or get [ __ ] and so i
think it's very interesting what twitter
did in the social media internet
business but then we're also talking to
massive retailers because they don't
like paying three percent if they can
pay zero percent right and so and
building on that and here's here's
another interesting story let me tell
you something uh the story of linux you
know this is a nerdy one um so for the
kids at home microsoft used to have the
monopoly on os
like these card processors or western
union does on their individual so let's
do visa that visa does on on processing
okay and microsoft took advantage of
that pricing was way too high customer
support was shitty product was never
innovative and what people did with
linux in the beginning what companies
would do is integrated air quotes flirt
with it a little bit hey visa there's
this open source thing everyone in the
world is building on it it's free and
yeah it may seem like a toy now and it
may seem like a nerdy pipe dream now but
i don't know it's free and it kind of
works and the principles are are sound
and moral
and so we're going to integrate it and
you know that
that thing you're charging at x bring
that down to y customer support responds
in two weeks bring that to two days you
guys release a new feature every two
years bring it to two months because if
not i'm gonna go use this free open
source thing and then all of a sudden
network effects built and enough people
started contributing resources to it and
linux became the dominant os and the
same thing is happening now it's like
hold on a second visa
you see this little network here yeah
it's cute yeah the kid in the hoodie in
that women's closet is funny but it's
you know interchange doesn't exist on
this network and then this company
integrates it and then a country
integrates it and then twitter
integrates it and then all of a sudden
it gets a little spooky and so i think
history doesn't repeat but it rhymes and
so i'll leave you with that
before i break any contractual
agreements and sharing secrets i'm not
supposed to all good keep going
jack nice when you think about um
the infrastructure itself talk to me
about the lightning network in terms of
where are we from a scalability
standpoint how much volume actually can
go through this thing and what are there
certain milestones or things that you're
looking for to say hey this goes from
you know pretty good now to absolutely
great and can handle global transaction
volume on the lightning network
um so firstly uh bitcoin and lightning
it's software and people don't
appreciate that so software's never
finished software is an iterative
process and you know western union and
going and walking to a physical branch
and waiting in line to pick up a paper
money that's not software that that
can't really improve much um and so it's
going to get better no matter how
successful we are or if we fail it's
going to continue day in day out get
better better better better um and so
can it handle global throughput yeah i'm
looking at my dashboard right now i'm
supporting the entire
twitter network and without even a hinch
in a murder beats hoodie so uh i think
that this network is is really
underappreciated i don't i don't think
people really appreciate i mean the
lightning network is a link to link
protocol just like the internet
if you can make an internet request you
can make a lightning network payment and
that scales tremendously and there's a
ton of trade-offs if you want
non-custodial if you want this feature
that feature and strike optimizes for a
different experience and so um is it
ready for everyone to have a
non-custodial version in their browser
that you know makes them bench 400
pounds no no of course not we're working
on it uh but is it ready today to
disrupt the entire world yeah yeah it is
and watch this watch this
and so when you think about uh educating
folks here what's really interesting to
me and i've always loved about uh strike
and kind of how you guys are doing this
nobody needs to know what bitcoin is
nobody needs to understand how it works
just like i don't understand how the
visa network works when i use it i don't
understand how paypal or stripe works
all i know is i either punch numbers in
i insert a card i tap i swipe whatever
and then they give me the good or the
service like i literally don't care how
the technology works just give me the
[ __ ]
that's exactly how you're building this
in a way where folks just say hey send
my five dollars it gets to where it
needs to get and i get back with good
the service you know i paid somebody
whatever and the infrastructure almost
doesn't matter to the end users in this
way which is very different than send me
bitcoin across this network uh learn
what a hex address is understand a
wallet etc
yeah listen to this user story uh family
in el salvador
um
in the time i stayed in el salvador
average income was three hundred dollars
a month
so a one hundred dollar remit payment
make or break a month
and because of fixed costs of the legacy
financial system sometimes fees on 100
remittance payment were upwards of 50
percent
took days to weeks and you had to bust
this family would have to bust four
hours to get to the western union branch
wait in line pick it up if a gang beat
them up or threaten them to take some
more of it well that adds to the fees
and then bus home so it's a day's worth
of chores you wait days to weeks and
western union and gangs are taking half
of the money that's so material to you
yesterday
that family
linked their strike account to their
twitter account
okay
the hundred dollars
was sent
to their twitter account
instantly and for free
and they just get dollars
they have no [ __ ] idea what bitcoin
is nor do they why who cares who don't
fire papoosa who cares
they just there what is this magic what
am i living in the future
money for 100 just got that used to take
50
weeks and a day's worth of chores and
sitting on a bus and then because el
salvador has integrated bitcoin they
turned around and bought coffee at
starbucks with their twitter i mean
you've got to be kidding me
nobody knew bitcoin was involved in that
at all and that's a material life that's
improving the quality of someone's life
keeping them safer giving them more
access to capital and building on
efficiencies that person is saving money
spending more time with their family so
there's a perfect user story they have
no idea what bitcoin is probably never
will who cares
so
i got two questions to end this the
first
a bunch of people are asking in the chat
do you care about the bitcoin price do
you have thoughts about where the
bitcoin price is going do you have
thoughts on the end of this year
oh yeah i mean i'm a trader uh by nature
my grandfather was the youngest chairman
of the chicago board of trade um
i think i mean
the monetary expansion that's happening
at central banks now is disgusting and
uh it's the easiest environment to make
money all you gotta do is not hold cash
[ __ ] if you put your couch on ebay
it'll it'll trade higher next week than
it does today so
um no i think we're going uh well into
the six figures uh when it happens um i
don't care i think within the next 12
months we'll see well over 100 000
bitcoin uh very easily
and and here's the thing for the
audience at home uh bitcoin's the only
monetary asset that humanity designed
with their bare hands we built this
thing from scratch and we built it to
appreciate against this exact
environment
it's not a gold rock we found it's not a
coin that came outside we literally sat
down and engineered this thing to pump
against what's going on and so don't be
surprised when it does um and yeah i
expect a hundred thousand to 250 000
maybe 400 000
bitcoin in the year 2022 easily
i love it
last question
you have the floor you're in the women's
closet you got the murder beats hoodie
on what's your message to the incumbents
what do you want them to know if i if i
clip this and i send it to him what's
the message to the incumbents
oh i'm here and i'm not going anywhere
you let the 27 year old in the hoodie
get a little too far um so come check up
and play in my court uh you can't run
you got to play
and uh and i'm gonna kick your ass so
clip that let's go
can we get uh john what was your
favorite line from the video yesterday
oh you said western union pawn to e4
your move
yeah there's my chess set right behind
me you see that
all right we got to play
i'd bet i'd beat the western union ceo
and chess blindfold
[Laughter]
you could you could beat john also not
even being in the room probably right
john yeah yeah maybe maybe why not
you know jack was what were you two-time
state champion chess player
yeah i'm not bad i'm not bad pawn to e4
carry some more weight
all right where can we uh where can we
send people to uh to download this thing
so we've got uh strike.me is that what
the best place to send people
strike.me you can find the mobile app
there you can access our api there and
as of this morning
uh we for the first time are in the top
charts of finance on the united states
app store everyone knows what we did in
el salvador so this thing's a rocket
ship and i appreciate all the support
and uh go check it out download it i'll
tip you on twitter
pawn to e4 my friend pawn to e4 all
right listen thank you for doing this uh
anyone who's got any questions tweeted
jack he uh he disappears from time to
time on twitter and then just comes back
with fire threads videos all kinds of
stuff and then everyone just erupts and
says oh [ __ ] that kid's back what's he
doing now so
keep up the great work
yeah love you boys thanks for having me
all right later
cheers what's up guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]